let's hit the wayback machine here a
little bit here uh
do these names remember these names
chansey stuckey
stuff uh jacoby ford ah a very fast wide
receiver yes you remember cj
spiller cj spiller took him early in
fantasy that year
tommy bowden head coach 2006 clemson
tigers
along with our next guest uh teammate of
all of theirs
uh his uh story from that 2006 season as
well as uh his
his time on campus at clemson university
has been made into a movie i cannot wait
to see on disney plus
that starts streaming next week called
safety the aforementioned safety from
those clemson tigers
is ray mcelrath be here on the rich
eisen show how are you ray
i'm doing well i'm doing great excited
about
everything that comes next i bet so
when did somebody reach out to you to
say let's make your story into a movie
right when did that happen that that
happened back in those six
no kidding uh long time ago
march artery uh mark charlie the
producer of the movie
as well as another gentleman a guy named
todd ellis
and said let's make a movie out of uh
what was going down on campus and let's
talk about what was going down on campus
involving your your brother feymar um
and and uh tell us the story uh uh
uh that happened and it's clearly the
inspiration for this film
yes uh one one foul summer
one fun summer my brother came to visit
um
from las vegas they were living at the
time he came to visit me at clemson
uh and due to my family situation my
mother
she was had addiction to crack cocaine
and my father
had uh was going through some tough
times as well um
due to that situation my brother feymor
didn't want to return home
he was staying in a weekly motel in las
vegas at the time
and the situation was dire and as
opposed to going back he
said he would rather go to foster care
and that's when i stepped in
um because i felt like that was a little
bit too far
and he asked could he stay and i thought
it would be the
better i did i couldn't do any worse and
that's what began
what set everything else in motion stay
on the campus
in the dorms with you at clemson yes
yes uh during my college football days
as me being a student athlete
yesterday stay on campus with me and he
was seven at the time
feymar seven years old well female was
eight
he was eight eight initially when that
turned to nine
then yes and then by the time the story
broke he was
video i i mean wow
so um what was it like to have
an eight nine year old in a dorm uh
also i imagine at the time uh you didn't
run it up the flagpole right you just
said
this is my brother he is not going to
foster care he's looking at me and
saying
hey ray what if i stay here and that's
the end of that
right that was what was going on yes it
was uh
it was not much to talk about at the
time because
um i had been told it was better to
apologize and ask for permission on this
particular situation
that's a good way to put it yeah so um
i kind of went because i wasn't sure
about what i wanted to do and how i was
going to go about doing it so that was
almost no there was no system in place
in which to deal with it
and so i i knew he was staying there but
how it was going to take place
i was unsure so i just told my roommate
like hey my brother's going to be here
for
a little while how long was a little
while i mean until we leave probably
probably
until we graduate and so
uh he was with it and we kept moving
kept it going it was a wonderful
situation i'm sure um
ray mcelrath be here on the rich eisen
show talking about the inspiration for
the movie safety based on his life and
times with his brother
uh in clemson um look i don't want to
give away too much
people need to see the film but um
was there a time when you thought that
this wasn't going to
stay the way that you wanted it to be is
there a time in this
um relationship with your brother that
this bond could have been
ripped apart based on real world saying
this can't be
this is not allowed right yes
um well there was not that uh
the ncaa is a villain but at the time i
was suspended by the ncaa due to
me breaking the rules that were in place
at the time
which was a student athlete couldn't
receive an extra benefit
because of their likeness and since
someone was only doing something for my
brother
because of my likeness then i was i was
suspended
in that situation but the ncaa came back
and and stepped in and
granted me a waiver one of the things
that they didn't have to do but they
stepped up
and took the uh
took the opportunity to do right by me
and i appreciate them for that and
here we are what did your teammates do
for you back in the day
oh man uh there's guys that uh i can put
up
bank i start with god rest and show
games adam she was another guy with my
thing
all right back in those days uh because
i heard you bring
up chances chances who wasn't the first
guys to you know start
hanging with my brother and picking them
up and keeping them when i didn't
necessarily have to hear them so
those guys were uh very privileged ft
waters
anthony waters was also a guy he ended
up playing tanks for a little while
um who was also there
for my brother not to mention all the
guys in my class the chris chancellors
of the world
the james davis paul muse uh
chris clemons uh a bunch of those guys
um stepped up and helped out and enough
to count
not to discount the clemson community of
course yeah because the community did
step up too right right ray i mean yeah
can you give me a little bit of uh
detail on that what they did when they
heard about yourself the coaching staff
at the time the spencer's uh coach rob
spence and his wife
uh coach sweeney and and his family uh
were very helpful at the time
uh just as far as picking up my brother
and dropping them off at school and
picking them up from school and things
like that uh the community came together
and they created a trust fund for my
brother
which was allowed by the ncaa to help me
take care of them and the clemson
community came through as well as the
overall overarching community of all the
clemson fans and
clemson family that i had luckily be a
part of
ray mcelrath be here on the rich eisen
show and you mentioned likeness
uh in terms of you know uh the
uh ncaa but when it comes to having
somebody portray them in a film
i mean the first choice is denzel let's
not let's not kid around
but uh even denzel would admit you know
uh the age
difference is tough to pull off um so
jay reeves is playing you the actor jay
reeves is playing you what was your
relationship with him and how you
downloaded him with the
the real stuff well uh men related
men jay relationships the queen became
very
intimate uh for the most part uh we knew
each other
very well once we began to film because
we only lived a mile away from each
other
in los angeles when he was uh when he
got the script
uh when he was also casted played me we
didn't know each other
before then but once he was scared to
play me he was giving me a call and we
turned that with the
less than a mile working less than a
mile and a half away from each other and
attended the same gym
so uh we were able to hook up
immediately when she was
getting given the role uh once he was
he rewarded the role and so we hung out
i let him meet my family
and everybody else in my family and
tried to get to know me better so he can
best portray me in the movie and uh how
much of your family
um uh is still around or
uh where is everybody today my whole
family is still around
a lot of times with the movie people
will only think that feymar is my only
sibling
but i have seven siblings i have three
three more brothers and four more
sisters and not to count the other
families that i was
part of because i was raised by my
coaches
um so um i guess athletic has been a big
part of my life the whole time so i have
other brothers and sisters from my
coaches families that i live with
growing up
and so that's kind of where i got
a lot of the ideas about people taking
care of or
getting temporary and extended custody
for kids because i went through the same
process as a young man myself
okay so um and
where's what's famar's memories of all
these times as a nine-year-old
uh fabor had a wonderful time as far as
i
know what he's told me people actually
still lives
uh right down the street from clemson i
only
you know visit uh for extended periods
of time in south carolina because i go
back and forth between there
south carolina atlanta and california
um but it's it's it's a wonderful
experience he's doing well he
he's excited about everything that comes
with the movie and uh
hopefully you'll probably give it a
chance to talk to him soon here
i know and him and my mother are also
helping me with my
foundation which is very safety net
foundation
and so it was just trying to help kids
like ourselves
make it through the struggle of the
especially during these times
and the the scenes were you know uh
clemson's coming on the field that looks
like the real
deal man this this looks like um
as as close to the real mccoy as you can
possibly get
these scenes well we were we were in
clemson yeah it was during the actual
game
so i guess it's the closest place we can
get
how cool is that that is amazing all
right so let's
let's let's uh again you know i'm sure
it's been a while since you've
uh competed uh you on the same field as
deandre hopkins go
what happens you and deandre
you mean deandre 101 yeah right what do
you got
i mean i i win the best out of ten he
gets
four okay all right so yeah
no i mean because we're clemson on
clemson you're
okay all right he's my guy he's he's
consistent as
as as most and he's probably the best
receiver in the nfl currently
and so uh okay until i
believe it's a lot to say that to him to
get
four out of ten okay so let's go let's
go okay
let's go ten snaps you're uh you you ray
macarappi are disguising your coverage
deshaun watson
go what do you got the sound wise yeah
um i go five for five i give them a
better chance
okay um we've been down passes are you
picking them off you're taking it to the
house i mean what do we have here right
come on i'm back down passes because uh
typically he
he extends to play which makes it a lot
a lot harder to cover whoever that's who
i'm checking so
it'll probably be me you know rallying
late
knocking down the pass as opposed to
picking and taking to the house
okay all right but let's be honest when
it all comes together though
um you're you come out on top regardless
of you know
whatever championships they might have
won or how close they can yeah
like that i understand it just just over
time i'm consistent that's that's what i
know if i stay consistent
and and and stick to whatever the method
is at the time
i i should come out on top but you're
all you're also awesome
there you go there you go long game but
you're also highly uh
community minded and really uh minded
people and
and and human beings first and um i i
cannot congratulate you
enough i mean this is this is amazing
your your life story is a disney movie
that's a fact and
and um congratulations on that to you
and your family and what's the name of
your foundation again so we can get
everybody's
uh hooked up with that it's a ray ray
safety net foundation ray ray safety net
foundation
okay everyone should go seek that out to
catch everyone
very good awesome uh ray congrats again
uh to you and your family enjoy all the
trimmings and uh of a movie coming out
with disney
and and all these and i appreciate you
joining us
on this program thank you i appreciate
you all for having me
you got it if we only can get through
this together so
just understand that i just want
everybody to know that you bet
thank you right back at you that's ray
mcelrath be here on the rich eisen show
everyone check out safety on disney plus
next week wow what a story right what a
story oh my gosh
what a story but uh deandre only gets
four off of him
we'll have to uh tag de'andre in that
video i don't know ray might be covering
him like the rest of the league which is
hack them the entire time and hope
there's no flag comes
that's true how many flags are thrown
heck of nuke
hackanook is happening no doubt about
that
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here